Hezbollah is burying its dead in its
stronghold in southern Beirut two of its
fighters were killed in Israeli
airstrikes in neighboring Syria on
Sunday night the Lebanese armed group is
promising retaliation it has told Israel
to be ready for a response its leader
Hassan Nasrallah also threatened to
shoot down any drone that violates
Lebanon's airspace after what he said
was an attack by Israeli drones in
Hezbollah's area of control in the
Lebanese capital hours earlier if we
remain silent on this breach it will
create a very dangerous road for Lebanon
repeating what is going on in Iraq now
in Iraq the Iranian backed popular
mobilization forces are blaming Israel
for a series of unexplained attacks on
their bases and positions in recent
weeks the latest was on Sunday night
close to Iraq's border with Syria which
killed a number of Fighters US officials
and Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu have hinted at possible
Israeli involvement in those strikes
Israel it seems has opened a new front
another Israelis are saying they're
ready to open war on three fronts Beirut
Damascus and Baghdad we can't ignore the
political side however which are the
upcoming Israeli elections the Israeli
army says its airstrikes in Syria
stopped an attack by Iran's
Revolutionary Guards it released
surveillance footage of what it said
were members of the Guards preparing a
drone strike against Israel Israel has
repeatedly hit what it says were Iranian
targets in Syria over the years it wants
to prevent Iran from gaining a foothold
and influence across the region but in
the past few days it is believed to have
operated in three neighboring countries
Lebanon Syria and Iraq Netanyahu did say
he gave his security forces a free hand
to act in many arenas against an enemy
state Hezbollah says the drone attack
which damaged its media office violated
the 2006 ceasefire and changed the rules
of engagement but at the same time the
group is believed to have given Israel a
chance
not to escalate tensions Hezbollah's
messages to the terre war nasrallah is
telling the israelis any war will be
costly and we are not alone so think
twice iran promised to support any
action Hezbollah takes against Israel
which doesn't seem to be backing down it
is believed to be behind strikes on a
position belonging to a Palestinian
faction allied to Iran along Lebanon's
border with Syria early on Monday there
is a real danger further attacks by
either side could escalate to war
senator al Jazeera Beirut